this is a good one right
so actually Bella Bella put this hmm
body is to go about not being interested
enough sex game is not one of mine sex
game is never gonna be a few minutes
agree for one yeah it's never gonna
happen
but this one I found interested and
insecure about not being interesting
enough that actually feel is like a real
thing
mmm because of what women aren't that
interesting yeah and we're gonna we're
gonna go in-depth in that as well not
because I've experienced it but because
a lot of people take things for face
value like let's say for example you see
a buff chick one Instagram and then you
see it out in real life and you think
[ __ ] you are laughs yeah I'll give my
soul to talk to you like that kind of
love and he actually start to talk to
someone and you're like I'm not even
interested all right you're and that's a
lot of females in this world boss a lot
of females because I don't need to be
interested because they're buff but that
that buffness clouds everything around
that person yeah yeah and it just
deteriorates them as a person because a
lot at the time yes you want more time
you're buff but you don't look like that
24/7 yeah yeah I'm not knocking people
looking natural because I love a natural
check anyway but there's only so far
looks can take you
Anderson I'm more obviously I'm not
attracted to you don't initially get
scared tracked it to personality I'm
attracted to looks mmm but if you've got
personality to match that we're rolling
because the fingers laughing the thing
is is like yes it sounds brutal but it's
[ __ ] true hmm in that if if I'm gonna
pursue something with you you could be
laughs buff buff buff but after I [ __ ]
you five times yeah I don't care about
yeah that's done now that's yeah that's
done so like if you ain't got the chat
there ain't never gonna go boring there
and I give a [ __ ] like they said what's
that saying like every beautiful girl as
a guy that's tired of [ __ ] her 135 is
facts if you're not interested
yeah just like leave me the [ __ ] alone
yeah it's not going anywhere further
looks very personality will never fade
if you're funny you're always gonna be
funny hunter if you've got great chat
you're always going to have great chat
and that this is the reason why a lot of
like so let's say for example I'm dating
a very very buff chick but it's just
like yeah a lot of people gas me saying
oh my god you're so lucky this you're so
lucky that driver but you only just know
that off face value because she looks
good and we look good together kind yeah
yeah and it's just like you don't know
what she's like behind closed doors you
don't know what she's like without
makeup which I'm not knocking by the way
you don't know what she's like in bed
you don't know what she's like when we
just haven't tryna talk via what's up or
something like that but on the rebuttal
of that let's say you've got you talked
to someone at work every single day she
might not be buff but because the
conversations you have our soul gang you
start to find things you're attracted to
about that's why it's everyone at work
[ __ ] this is one time that's why work
is so sexual Rob always offers [ __ ]
going on in every office everywhere
every workplace everywhere there's
because because you spent all this time
with people you get to know down there
and you find out actually pretty
interesting and even though you didn't
find them attractive initially they can
find things that you life-span cool I'd
actually [ __ ] this [ __ ] so yeah if
you're buff ladies you're buff stop just
being buff yeah come with a chap yeah be
interesting please please finally do
something man because why is he spot you
a few times said after that yeah there's
nothing left to it because literally
enough to it there isn't it was any
other responses not really but that one
I found that one the most interesting
because I thought its I'm glad is a
concern because it should be yeah it
should be a concern you need to have
some game my new self some chat for
females anyway because you can't just
stem off your look so long you can't
just them off Beauty alone
mmm-hmm so I had something that actually
really really want to talk about I found
it so fascinating and it's something
I've always found fascinating which is
the concept are we boy up earlier
concept of an open relationship yeah so
I was listening to a podcast every day
with this guy who had tried out in her
firm relationship mm-hm and he was
talking about kind of the peaks and
troughs and it kind of goes back to what
we were saying about being vulnerable
and all these things yeah and he said
the highs were [ __ ] high yeah but the
lows were
like in like yeah and it was kind of
trying to determine whether or not it
was ever even worth it yeah and he was
talking about what obviously the obvious
highs are in comparison to what the
unsuspecting lows were so obviously
concept over a nation ship you're with
someone you both agree okay we love each
other we want to continue to love each
other but we're also interested in the
Explorer in a sec excuse me Jesus
exploring our sexuality with other
people mm-hmm so he had done that he was
sleeping with four girls or this or this
or this was she sleeping with other guys
she's sleeping with other guys and they
come back to it and the lows were
stemming from honeymoon periods with the
other check yeah so not not necessarily
with the other chicks but even though he
was having them with the other chicks
knowing because with the open relays I
think a big part of the open
relationship you can take it one of two
ways yeah in that you can agree to not
ever discuss it you do what you're doing
yeah well if you want to truly embrace
it yeah truly embrace it and truly
accept it you discuss it and you came
from [ __ ] brave yeah so I think he
was the one where he was trying to
discuss it and basically he was he
wasn't anticipating the his his partner
going through honey material guys
because he at the end of the day it is
kind of like a I don't even know I'd
like a double-edged sword in know you
what a guy wants in an open relationship
it's probably just a [ __ ] loads of
different girls yeah so he's probably
not gonna find himself in too many
honeymoon periods yeah because he's more
inch because he already has a partner
yeah he's more interested in just
[ __ ] which is what guys do yeah so
the the appeal of being an open ratio
for a guy it's just a [ __ ] [ __ ] [ __ ]
[ __ ] and like you just not [ __ ] the
same girl all the time just [ __ ]
[ __ ] [ __ ] [ __ ] and then that's
just one scratch of one itch and then
you come back to your wife's and you're
happy like you haven't you hey can you
eat like you'll set but what you didn't
expect is that your planet doesn't want
to do that she might want to have sex
with other guys but she doesn't want to
[ __ ] a million million guys yeah there's
no appeal it man
yes you have one or two or three and he
didn't expect to come home and find her
so obsessed with a different guy because
he doesn't give a [ __ ] about the other
girls he just wants to [ __ ] come home
to his wife yeah she still loves him but
she's coming home and she's like she's
in a honeymoon period she can't wait to
see you next man again and he's out what
you mean you can't wait to see another
guy again like with sorrow no we're here
together like who do you mean II can't
wait to see this guy again yeah and he
was saying like every time she would go
out to see my man like he would
literally he said for one night I think
it was the first night yeah about of the
open-air shoot where she actually went
out to [ __ ] a guy yeah and that she'd
been talking to him stuff he spent the
entire night throwing up and crying in
the toilet Jesus throwing up and crying
knowing that his wife's getting banged
and he had no option but to firm it see
you double-edged sword man broth it's
horrible it's hard now I was thinking
that do you think you could ever have an
open relationship
no for all of the pros the pros
obviously cause is it selfish like you
said you want your cake in 20 years well
like I the thought of it is is cool in
terms of the fact that she's happy and
allowing me to go and [ __ ] whoever I
want to [ __ ] no feelings attached yeah
I'm coming back to you you're my wife
you're my woman but if you flip don't
think she's she's obviously not gonna go
I'm just [ __ ] because women get mostly
attached for Garland's yes
regardless even if they respect that
person once they're still gonna stem in
their brain so if she finds something
more than just sex from someone else in
terms of like communication abroad
that's why say personality is key yes if
you find someone even close to what her
husband is or something on a completely
different tangent actually that opens up
a brain even more he's I'm gonna be like
[ __ ] I [ __ ] up let's close this whole
relationship thing guys it's done
because I don't know it's a very selfish
thing to have I think in my opinion from
a guy's perspective because the guys
just want to [ __ ] where anyway if the
girls if the girls are just [ __ ] and
it's just sex I would still be annoyed
even though I am [ __ ] other chicks
but I wouldn't be that much annoyed yeah
because I'm just [ __ ] chicks and
she's just [ __ ] guys yeah 100 set but
if she starts to get physically and
emotionally attached or attracted to
someone else nah yeah
Marvis I'm fine not very loose cuz what
do you mean you're taking my woman to
another firm would you mean there on
date nah and he was saying another in a
weird way this is kind of like carcasses
were actually in a weird way when she'd
come back and he'd have it would also
turn him on a little bit more in like a
weird way in that obviously he knows
that she's coming back she got [ __ ]
last night so when he [ __ ] her he he
knows he's to lay it all right cool
like she's coming home he's out I need
to smash her back [ __ ] doors in yeah
like I have to she needs to remember why
she's home
she's never way these four walls is
where she resides and she can step out
all of this yeah anyway she wants but
when she's coming home she's getting
tight
yeah and he said it used to turn him the
[ __ ] on and that used to [ __ ] with his
head even more because he's getting
turned on about the fact that his wife's
getting [ __ ]
and he's like having her back home athos
like it was a weird concept it was
[ __ ] with his head massively and like
in the sense of that also what he also
didn't anticipate was the fact that he
was happy to be open with the girls that
he was [ __ ] that he's in the open
relationship they quite enjoyed the fact
when they agreed to like to [ __ ] him and
stuff they quite enjoyed the fact that
he was in a relationship so they treed
the relationship with him as an open
relationship as well and he said he'd
fought one girl and there were children
in bed together and then she sent a nude
to another guy why he was in the bed oh
wow bro
sent a new to another guy when he was in
the bed and he was like what the [ __ ]
yeah if she was out what would you mean
other for like you're an urban issue of
your wife yeah I'm not even the one
you're in an open relationship with like
well yeah he was just like he just said
he felt lost yeah lost yeah like what
have I got yeah like every everyone's
just [ __ ] everyone in this euphoria
and it's amazing but when it comes out
of what the [ __ ] off I got like is this
crazy I think miss people misconstrue
that idea of an open relationship they
just think about him says I think yes
I'm just gonna [ __ ] but I've still got
something back a hundred percent but
it's the reality of it is not that Boyle
not
no I'm not experiencing I don't think I
ever watch what I never want to mmm but
from that story alone it just cements
the fact that it's not cool it's just
not it's not practical it's not it's not
practical it's not practical the only
practical thing to do is cheat facts in
facts
yuichi whoever you want
and she doesn't [ __ ] anyone Oh win win
win win cheat single edged sword now be
obviously I'm playing but Jesus fam it's
just like a crazy one because it's like
the reason it really hit home of me in
terms of what you were saying before
yeah
is that moments in the last episode
about you need to just snatch whatever
you want and be happy yeah as much as
you can stuff like that that was someone
who really really really was trying to
find true happiness yeah and being open
the fact about like but this is the
happiness that I want yeah I want to
explore it and it just made him [ __ ]
depressed
mm-hm and it was like human just made me
realize that [ __ ] being a human being
is so fickle
yeah there's no right or wrong to
anything yeah there's all everything is
just filled with emotion and stress and
love and happiness of war and all this
stuff and just like you get to agreeing
parties to be an open relationship and
in hindsight that sounds like the
sexiest best thing ever
yeah and at times it is yeah but boy
that when it's not it's like there's no
I want to kill myself yeah I wanted to
[ __ ] kill myself your relative is
ridiculous not again not talking from
experience but I can only imagine I
wouldn't want to be in that situation
and wouldn't ever want to be in that
situation I say man and I think I've
always I always wish I was brave enough
to want to try it but just know not and
that's another thing like I said I was I
wish I was into more stuff that's one of
those things that I wish I was brave
enough to be like alright [ __ ] it - try
it yeah but it would have to be it
wouldn't even ever be in an operation
because the only person I'd be here to
do if someone I don't really care about
yeah say wouldn't be relation she
wouldn't even yeah I wouldn't be word
for in the first place because the only
person I could be brave enough to deal
with it with someone I really can [ __ ]
about yeah that's pointless elmo's will
be single
Oh cheap just cheap no don't play no
cheat but this is another okay I just
wanna I feel like I need a break I need
a breaking conversation just to make
clear for the ninth ninth time don't
condone cheating but obviously in the
you sounds stupid like this is the whole
thing like like I said like being a
humanist fickle yeah it's being a
humanist fickle and I've been trying
really really really hard to have like
an open perspective on everything yeah
and when I said about the same way when
I said about the marriage thing yeah and
the Judah tradition thing yeah in that
people like to whitewash stuff yeah and
people like to to paint everything and
just say and make out like real life
isn't real yeah and like yeah people
have to make up a real life isn't real
when it is and certain aspects of real
life aren't pleasant mm-hmm but facts
are facts yeah of course and one of the
ones that I was thinking about was again
I don't know why's always comes up but I
find it's such a fascinating topic was
kind of like lying and cheating and
stuff not necessarily cheating per se
but that the the act of lying is is such
a powerful thing so in terms of people
always think that like honesty is the
best policy
yeah now I was think about the silver
day cuz my brother I can't remember I
spoke about it's already or not but
maybe I haven't and but basically my
brother tom is still really kind of it
kind of set me in like a weird sense of
perspective and I was just like wow like
this is crazy because basically so my
brother told me the story about his
friend yeah she's a girl so she was
engaged to a guy in a fiance he's a
rugby player right okay so he got
offered a contract in Germany
okay so they went off they planned
everything to move to Germany yeah I'm
probably butchering this story is like a
third hand story by now so yeah
anyway moving to Germany they're going
in like a matter of days and he'd gone
over a week or two earlier whatever it
was to sort out the apartment to get
settled with the team all this stuff
yeah and then lo and behold while he's
out there she gets a message on facebook
from some random girl saying basically I
[ __ ] your fiancee oh I've been [ __ ]
your fiancee German yeah in Germany
while he was over there so while he's
over there he's been [ __ ] some girl
okay okay okay
the girl he gave her he must have given
her in so Facebook or whatever saw all
over his Facebook that he was engaged as
you know yeah so she got a sense of
morality and message to go and said I've
been [ __ ] your your fiancee or
whatever okay so fast forward to present
day they're no longer together yeah
they're movie very much she quit her job
sold their flat all these things to move
to Germany they were engaged to be
married and the way obviously you've got
this simple version so the simple
version is he's a dog he shouldn't be
cheating he's got caught out he's gonna
break this girl's heart yeah all this
stuff but then there's always two sides
to every story here and the way I saw it
I obviously I saw it the way it's
supposed to be seen which is that yeah
but the way I also saw it was right
realistically speaking what are the odds
that this was the first time that he
ever cheered yeah
slim as [ __ ] slim as [ __ ] yeah first of
all rugby players cheat like crazy from
white rugby guys brav they love to [ __ ]
guys so if they're definitely [ __ ]
girls yeah me them rugby initiations
really guys are next thing so yeah I
don't know if you're white you play
rugby boy your Chi and you're nasty
but yeah these rugby guys I was soon as
soon as he said he was wrongly IOC he
just cheats for banner any inter anyway
so I thinking right realistically
speaking what are the odds that it's the
first time he's cheated and slim and
knowing that he was and and not knowing
that
he'd still managed to progress his
relationship to a point where they were
engaged to be Wed yeah and that he was
moving his fiancee over to a different
country so they could start a life
together in Germany so he clearly loved
this woman obviously he clearly loved
her and he'd love to get dick where the
same plan yeah so he's done a good
enough job up into this point to not get
caught and their relationship is
flourished and the fact that his fiancee
did not know about any of it and allowed
her to invest herself in a red ship and
she was up in to the point where she got
that marriage I mean that message she
was happy happy truly happy that she's
got a man there moved to Germany and I'm
still asking of us so up into that point
yeah they were [ __ ] happy yeah now
soon is this nosy [ __ ] [ __ ] message
to go yeah that's all done now that's
all done yeah and yes he shouldn't have
been doing it yeah at the say might even
say but cuz there was no button yes he
shouldn't have been doing it and at the
same time who gained anything from that
girl sending the message yeah because
what joy did it bring to anyone's life
and no one nothing what benefit did it
bring nothing what benefit did it bring
you you [ __ ] up a happy relationship
yeah and yes people would say he [ __ ]
up he did but technically he actually
did it if you want to get yet if you
want to get technical he didn't [ __ ] up
because he's been Chee yeah 100% Benji
is Benji he's benching him from day one
hundred percent she's just not blocked
it yeah he's just covered up his tracks
well enough that they didn't get clot
yeah and yes he did [ __ ] it up but he
[ __ ] it up because he allowed his girl
to get his facebook that's how he [ __ ]
it up yeah comfortable he got comped he
got wake up before he was in a different
country so it's played as a mouse dick
dick dick 84 as the different countries
is safe not these days brother not these
days you are place tomorrow but yeah for
real I was like it sounds like that a
misogynistic way to think about it yeah
but I like to think about it in every
which way in every aspect in every
theory yeah ruff and I was literally
just thinking wow if she'd never done
that mmm then everyone would have
continued to their life and it made me
think like let me actually think about
this if I was with someone and we'd been
married forever
and then we've been married for 50 years
and I love her and everything about our
relationship is fine yeah we have good
sex we have a good family we have good
house we have good morals and we love
each other and we have a great
relationship yeah
when after all these 50 years dude I
want anyone to tell me that she's been
cheating the entire time of course not
no of course not ignorance is bliss
leave me the [ __ ] out after said it well
brav ignorance is bliss leave me alone
because I'm happy yeah and all that
matters is that I'm happy that's
literally it as far as I'm concerned in
my life all that matters is that I'm
happy reversal of that she could have
had an intuition that it was cheating
but she was ignorant in the fact so it
was bliss she could have found it that's
another thing is you alright because I
actually had that perspective his book
yeah she could have had an inkling that
she was but in her mind the relationship
was more motivated was more important
than trying to find out what trying to
find out the true of every tree and not
because she liked what she had and then
when the inclination had been smacked in
her face and there was no other way of
avoiding it yeah apart from being an
absolute mug yeah I just deleting the
message and moving on here was obvious
you can do mm-hmm
up into that point she might've had an
inkling um I thought you know [ __ ] it I
love this guy I want to get my disco I
want to do these things like if he's
cheating my that's just not even burials
in there listen I'm not gonna check his
phone I'm not gonna do with these things
like and like there's a stupid there's a
stupid thing and I say stupid thing but
there's a there's like this concept
called like the French like the the
French concept or the French tradition I
comment was called or the French Way of
life and basically I don't know if it's
it's an historic kind of mindset but
basically says that like with the French
Way of life is in France you kind of
have a you you you're you're married or
whatever and it's assumed that your
husband or your wife or wherever is a
cheap where is this you it's assumed you
just go on the premise that you assume
that they're cheating okay and it's not
the fact that they're cheating is the
disrespect yeah but if they are so
lackluster as to allow you to find out
that they're cheating that's the
disrespect
okay so it's not necessarily the fact
that you [ __ ] someone yeah that's the
disrespectful part it's the fact that
you were so lazy about it that you
didn't even care about my feelings
enough that to protect me to protect ya
yes you allowed this girl to mess so
that's where this guy [ __ ] up so this
is where he got disrespectful because he
didn't respect his relationship enough
to stop this girl from from from finding
his fiancee and messaging and hurting
his fiance's feelings yeah like that's
where he [ __ ] up the most yeah and
something in some stupid way I do I'm
not good like I said in my dream but I
do kind of subscribe to that mmm in that
like a lot of guys get caught out
cheating and that's a that's a that's a
lackluster way to do your thing if if
you're only if your only motivation is
[ __ ] yeah then allow that to be your
only motivation and get your [ __ ] in
order yeah if your only motivation is
[ __ ] because everyone know there's no
point beating around the bush there's no
point being in denial lots and lots on
lots of guys and girls cheap lots of
[ __ ] people cheat yeah lots of people
but if you're if the sex is your sole
motivation yeah then for the love of
[ __ ] God be up front like yet cover
your [ __ ] tracks be up front and
don't allow people to don't lie to go so
you can [ __ ] him and tell him you love
and you're single and all this yeah like
should you just be a front get what you
need to get and be out yeah and then
yeah try it your best to be happy man
and try your best to pick upon a buddy
[ __ ] it I don't just don't cheat but if
you need to really must do bleep you
must do it the right way
[Laughter]
boy I can't keep getting back on his
topic cause it sounds makes me sound
like a serial cheat yeah funny though
but it's the reality things that people
love to ignore yeah people love dig
noise like you hear it all the [ __ ]
time nah he cheated she cheated
I've caught in taxing this person or she
was sending news and say you hear it all
the time but people love to play
ignorant like it doesn't happen and it's
it like people little bit ignorant like
oh man there's [ __ ] there's [ __ ] guys
you'll find a good guy so sex it's not
necessarily just [ __ ] guys it's just
like all guys mm-hmm and like especially
if you're an attractive
you get a lot a lot of dick thrown your
way or you get a lot of [ __ ] thrown
your way I think you said it before I
don't know where you're setting this
podcast or you've said it to me it's
just in general but it's harder to is
easy to say no to one person it's let's
say Oh V for example ovie from love
island he must get DMS from [ __ ]
every single day 24/7 he's eventually
gonna say yes of course he's eventually
gonna he's gonna find one thing a thing
rah do you know I mean it's harder to
say no how much thousand girls a
thousand times a day above 100% yes so
easy to say no that one time once in
your life or once a year Jeff Ron
account in says no once and he gets home
to his wildebeest of a wife and he's got
a big deformed sense of morality because
he had he said no to Sharon she [ __ ]
anyway he's got his ego bit strange man
I'm a faithful guy Sharon wants his dick
I ain't gonna give it to her mmm but I'm
feeling good yeah as soon as Jeff gets
[ __ ] it launched at him Almighty for
seven because he's a buff guy it's hard
to say no and it was like when a simple
like footballers get caught out cheating
all the time Stern all the time why
though because they're rich and they're
buff yeah and the boys buff the finger
they're not even - they're just rich and
they've got the status and girls want to
be associated with that state yeah so
they get [ __ ] all the time yeah they
get caught with the time because they
get [ __ ] thrown out on one yeah and
they're on camera 24/7 yes true as well
but yeah so you even know what the mole
story was but I I just think like it's a
messy world trying to be happy at the
same time yeah but yeah tape people's
feelings into consideration but [ __ ] now
that that open relationship thing truly
brewing my mind but yet I guess what I
try to say ignorance is bliss ignorance
is bliss I like sometimes is as
backwards as it sounds I'd rather not
know when they say that I'll what they
don't know won't hurt them as a faculty
as it sounds fact it's actually a fact
because like you said if I've been
married and happy for 50 years and
someone comes to confide in me saying
you're a big man she's been cheating for
like 20 years that's gonna shatter my
whole I mean you've ruined my life
yeah you've ruined every favor in my
life you've ruined everything
you
everything you're not my friend don't
tell me you've ruined everything and I
was [ __ ] happy I was dyed happy yeah
you [ __ ] ruined everything it's a
hard pill to swallow because it makes
once you find out it makes you think did
she love me or did he love me your
question your entire life yeah you
question everything like was he just
saying because we had kids or what she
just and it's like people I don't think
she in this cheating and there's desert
if there's a fez do two different things
mmm so if he or she is a serial cheat
and just just likes dick but doesn't get
as much gratitude regret there was the
word I'm looking for gratification yeah
from that certain somebody they look
elsewhere not saying they should but
that's that's the murder so right now
they're looking elsewhere but if they're
having a full-blown affair with another
person just a singular body that's
different yeah that's very day you've
done you've solidified the fact that you
don't love me anymore yeah a hundred
percent you solidified fact that you're
just coming home because it's convenient
yeah yeah hundreds in an affair will
always lead to a decision
yeah and decision will either be you
ever leave your man or girl or you [ __ ]
me off because the purse the third party
is gonna want to know what you want to
do because I love her or should I love
or she loves him do you know I mean
hundreds in and if you're not gonna come
with me you need to go yeah yeah so
that's very different unfair and she in
a two different fit if she's having a
full-blown affair for X amount of years
mmm and you tell me then that will
solidify the fact that I knew for a fact
she wasn't happy we should just didn't
have the boss to end it or the balls to
tell me 100 percent so there's a fine
line it's still [ __ ] it's all she is all
[ __ ] it's all [ __ ] but there is a
difference yeah it's all [ __ ] and the
thing is as well as the fact that I'm
not even saying to the things that I
think the point is what I'm trying to
make is that I'm not encouraging this
kind of behavior if you're not doing
this kind of behavior I'm not
encouraging that you do I'm just saying
that it's stupid to ignore the fact that
a lot this behavior happens on a
consistent basis every day and a day
everyone's just trying to get their
jollies off but everyone's trying to be
as happy as they possibly can yeah for
as long as they can so if you're if
you're gonna try and be happy and you
ain't gonna stop trying to be happy then
do it in a manner that respects your
partner
stupid as it sounds in a disrespectful
manner that you're doing it trying to be
as respectful as possible and like cuz
hear stories about like ah I clocked him
cheating because there's [ __ ] I come
home this [ __ ] knickers in the in the
front room or something like okay that's
disrespectful
thank it if you don't care about your
partner find finding out then you just
[ __ ] up yeah like you just [ __ ] up
and that's just out of order like you
deserve to get caught yeah you don't
love that person do not if you can get
caught with nicotine in your house fam
you don't love you buying a house in the
first place don't love your house
partner um yeah a lot of people are
trying to [ __ ] and they love their
partner and like I said before with
people when they said about like get
yourself a side man stuff like that
there are serious serious situations
especially for women because it's hard
for a woman to find sexual gratification
yeah like genuine like yeah a guy can
get [ __ ] and a lot of the time like ten
out of ten [ __ ] and five out of temper
see is like a thin line didn't line it's
just a nut what's up once you've succumb
to the fact that I don't actually like
you but once you're in there it's the
same euphoria because once I'm banging
your back doors in yeah to me you could
be anyone you could be anyone it's just
sex
yeah yeah yeah and when I'm about to
climax it's just sex
yeah great if you're 10 out of 10 if
you're to attend even five had said it
doesn't make a difference what the
difference is after I bust my knot yeah
when you win or draw when you out yeah
yeah yeah obviously for a woman like I
said with the episode the other day it's
like yeah they can find someone that
takes nine out of ten boxes yeah but
that temp box is the dick game in the
dick game is terrible
yeah it [ __ ] with their entire week
yeah everything so if they need feel the
need to like why I don't want to lose
this person like they say they want it
out are you trying to get happy in it so
that they don't want to lose this person
that they've got they they love and
respect this person but they need some
say for gratification on somewhere and
they're gonna go they're gonna go get in
it mmm so like the [ __ ] I was talking
about don't even know the [ __ ] I was
talking about
guys well I'm sure you guys get the
marled yeah yeah we're just gonna run
anyway yeah but yeah they get the
[ __ ] point that's funny
moving on moving on this is funny
actually in terms of what you just said
this is perfect right I have an open
mind right just have an open mind yeah
yeah so I'm gonna hate you know when you
said just now like if it's a 2 out of a
10 or a 10 out of 10 yeah like sex is
sex and when you're in a you're in it
and you don't care yeah a situation say
if you get sucked off yeah best head
you've had in in forever yeah and you
not not not yeah the girl was banging
mmm not deep and it was just like the
best and you just go home happy yeah lay
on you find out was guy now listen I
knew saying like that was coming later
on you find out was a guy yes it was a
trainee so yeah yeah I don't think
trainees like an appropriate time
anymore I was thinking is he over there
I figure that's a trainee anymore so I
laughs a trans a person who's trans yeah
your present is trans yeah so is
splitting hairs in the diaper and there
were persons trans and it was a guy
still has a dick hmm but they sucked you
off hmm now does it make you gay if when
you think back on it yeah it's as you
are I don't know that's tough because at
the time I was getting my dick sucked I
wasn't aware this guy or this girl was a
guy yeah you weren't yeah your idea of a
guy yeah you're attracted to your
pervert idea of a woman yeah [ __ ] that's
put me on the spot indeed doesn't make
me gay if I think back if you think back
and you get hard-on does that make you
gay now knowing that you you was a guy
who was a guy I want to say no because
the is hard to explain like knowing the
fact that I didn't know it was a guy or
a trans my brain automatically woman my
brain just thinks I'm getting very good
head that's what my senses are telling
me so when and when you think about
something you're thinking about
something that's happened like my brain
is trying to recreate what happened yeah
yeah so yeah my brain is gonna be like
thinking back and think oh [ __ ] this guy
he's a guy there's gonna be thinking
about about the fact that I had a really
good head yeah so I think thinking back
about it doesn't make me gay because
it's just my brain trying to recreate
something true and I can't help the fact
that I didn't know it was a trans yeah
but with in the same breath knowing that
I now know it's a trans would I go back
right that was gonna be my next so you
get the good sucks a good suck night
deep you find out was a guy you think
back on it turns you on best head you've
ever [ __ ] your head and then you get
texts like round round two with the
tongue out that winky tongue out ready
you did get solid are you gay if you go
back again yes there's a difference
because I now I have now I have all the
information you have all the information
but at the same time its head so you're
not gonna be fine no you're not gonna
sign you know you're not only gonna see
a woman's face a woman's tits like a
woman shaker that's all you're gonna see
mmm and you know they had his top top
top does it make you gave you go back
yeah because now I know it's a guy well
now I know it's a guy trying to be a
female here so yes of course it makes me
gay okay and as I've said in previous
episodes I I'm not homophobic any other
sort like if own what you are I've
worked and worked with so many new
people lesbians
by whatever so I'm not knocking out so
it doesn't affect me or
it's just my personal view on it so okay
now the next question yeah
now you've establish it makes you gay if
we go back yes in my opinion yeah yeah
yeah are you going back wait let me talk
talk why thank you so long I'm not going
back okay but okay but I'm not going
back and that's that's a standard all
right cool but like I said I would think
about it not think about going back but
I'll think about the time I got the head
yeah because my brain is only gonna
recreate white new yeah yeah and if you
like you said it's the best set of ever
had in my life is tonight said and as
I've said in the past or said in
previous episodes I find it hard to come
from head yeah hard to come from here
you do and if I don't know why I said
you do such confidence and if that
person made me not easily easily easily
gobbledy affirm I'm obviously gonna
think about it not think about going
back but think about when it happened
mmm but within the same brief I wouldn't
go back hmm
but I still want to go back but I would
contemplate going back yeah wouldn't go
that's the thing yeah because there will
be a time where I'm drunk and I ever see
the person or the person either text me
I'll contemplate that's the difference I
wouldn't go back but contemplate because
my brain is gonna recreate what I yeah
yeah yeah your boss is gonna get tight
for a guy but you know I'm speaking
about that's funny you know when there
was like you know when like lady boys
were like a trend yeah like Thai lady
boys were a trend and there's always
documentaries about guys that ended up
like these English guys that were going
out Thailand marry and native boys and
stuff for Danny's like I'm not gay I'm
not gay I'm not gay
yeah and then obviously it was so easy
at the time like if you're gay you're
gay okay yeah there's no two ways about
it yeah when you actually think in debt
so like in that situation you get sucks
because that's probably what happened
here
we didn't initially in this initial
holiday to Thailand I hide out he was
searching for a [ __ ] yeah but he
probably got moved to by a very
attractive woman they sucked him off
yeah gave him
anal quickness just didn't know it was a
guy just didn't know was a guy he had
probably had some of the best sex he's
ever had
cuz they're all like middle-aged white
guys and like probably married for 20
years or just recently divorced had mad
sex with some banging Thai girl and then
later on they found I was a guy and then
I [ __ ] and then like you said they
contemplate their think back and then
the Thai guys texting off like brother
I need that pic of my throat again and
they're thinking Jesus [ __ ] and the only
difference is now it's big man they're
on holiday holiday vibe is different
holiday bible is different no what
they're what happens in Thailand and
they're not [ __ ] and that contemplation
turns to a push mmm buff who's gonna
know he's gonna find out who's gonna
know I'm horny I'm drunk I'm in Thailand
no one else is here no one knows me yeah
like obviously my man wants to suck me
off it looks like a girl I'm pretty
certain it feels like a girl knows I
could go yeah this last time let me get
this last enough and then I'll go back
to England they'll never think about it
yeah yeah they suck and finally like
Jesus Christ and then there's more
justification there they like Jesus
right now I'm certain is it gonna come
sir does it go like I went the first
time fella as a girl minute second time
like it's a go it's a girl girls and
they just to find out it's a girls girls
girls girls go and as long as they never
come home it's a girl
so it's staying silent forever phone
that's why because none of these men
moved at 80 boy back to England
when all the documentaries all the
things I say the guy never brings the
[ __ ] betting they always just move
out of Thailand so you always get these
Thai Brides that come to England and
they're like the guy buys them online or
whatever and then come to England that's
their their life in England now I know
there are always women when it's the
lady good boy yeah
he knows he can't bring it home
he can't bring that to his doorstep
fantasies over yeah yeah anyone living
with a guy yeah yeah yep
so um boys crazy money it's crazy
because yeah I used to think
but okay you're gay gay alright you
answer step bite now no you have to
cause that Martin so you didn't know the
same example you didn't know what the
trends
yes sucked off Mariah and then you find
out what are you doing um I don't know I
feel like this long-winded I feel like
the long winded way has made me kind of
concrete in the fact that that's no like
a straight no but when I was describing
it to you I was like trying to visualize
it nice thinking man I'd be hard maybe
it would definitely be hard and I think
yeah I think I'm on your your thing is I
do think I would I think the thing with
me is I don't think I would struggle to
say no mm-hmm because I I would know I
think it would like to me the [ __ ] off
another no no no no but I am also now on
the fence or whether or not I think is
gay or not if you go back I'm on the
fence more now you go back
yeah after knowing if I go back I'm more
on the fence now even though I know I'm
not going back yeah
I'm not going back because I think is
gay yeah I'm going back in the nicest
way possible I'm not going back cuz I'm
repulsed yeah in the nicest way yeah
yeah I'm going back because I'm reports
because that's just not what I'm into
yeah no I'm saying like yeah I'm not
into whether I think is gay or not I'm
not into the concept of a guy sucking me
off yeah so as soon as I know that I'm
turned off yeah there's no reason for me
to go yeah but I am now more on the
fence of whether it's gay or not I don't
I'm not sure I think is gay or not as
long as you can truly truly convince
yourself yeah that it's not guy or
whatever justifications you need yeah
they say is not a guy hmm
but you know what blows my mind off talk
off topic but still on topic mmm
pansexual people so obviously we
discussed what they were yeah yeah so
imagine a guy transforming into a girl
to make her damn selves happy and it go
transfer himself to a guy to make
themselves happy and both of them to get
together
I know it happens that's why it's mine
bro because it's like with it why we did
not be the same if you both just stayed
the same yeah I mean because it's still
a guy with the girl and a girl with a
guy but the guy is now chained to a girl
to be happy and a gay guys the girl is
not chained to a guy to be happy but
then you meet each other and you both
find out you're both trans as well as
pants also another thing as well does it
make you a hypocrite if you're a for
example if you're a trans female so you
were born male yeah you transitioned
into a female yeah and then you meet
someone um who is the vice versa
yeah so you born so born no eh yeah born
female transition to male and you find
that person physically attractive but
because you know they were born the
opposite sex
you wouldn't [ __ ] it the same way I
wouldn't [ __ ] yeah yeah yeah you don't
[ __ ] it does that make you a hypocrite
if I was the trans person 100% that
makes me hypocrite 100% do you think
that happens though do I think happen I
think it must happen I think it's rare
because I think the likelihood of fat
muc to be fair I don't think it's that
rare but it's I think it's niche it's
not rare its niche yeah yeah there's
obviously a trance and pants culture in
every country probably but that's the
thing was like what I'm trying to say is
just because you're trans does that make
you pan I don't think it does it doesn't
but I'm saying if my my rebutted is that
I feel like if you then find out the
person you are seeing was also a trans
and you're obviously that does then make
you a pan I'm saying these words like I
said casual I feel lost my shirt full I
don't know what you're trying to say bro
he does you saying it does make them
hypocrite right it does make them okay
if they don't [ __ ] with that person yeah
I feel like it personally makes them
hypocrite purely because I agree youth
myself if I'm a transsexual myself I
have gone through stages of where I
don't feel like I'm comfortable as a man
I want to be a woman I feel like I'm a a
man a woman born inside a man's body
that's my personal view and I've changed
to a be a woman to be happy but so now
you're mentally a woman and your physic
woman so it's all blessed it's all black
in your head yes - bless so for that on
someone else - for you to not want
someone else because they felt the same
thing but the complete opposite and you
still find them physically physically
and sexually attractive but you know for
a fact she was a woman turned into a man
and now you're opposed that in my in my
head that makes me hypocrite a hundred
percent agree I would love to know
whether how often that happens because
I'm I reckon it happens a lot I don't
know why I think it happens a lot
I just I just think it does I don't I
don't know I think it may happen a lot
in certain parts of the world like
places probably America Thailand
probably places in England as well that
are open about transsexuality and
sexuality because a lot of countries on
yeah a lot of countries on but the
countries that are open about I feel
like it happens more often than not but
I just feel like it's a very very very
it's a niche topic oh dude super niche
it's very speculative yeah I wouldn't I
would never be able to collect the date
I would need to Eve yeah yeah yeah where
because I'm never going to be a
transsexual you're never gonna be a
transsexual I'm never gonna be a
pansexual so I'm only going off what I
feel like is right or wrong
yeah and that's just my opinion yeah
yeah yeah exactly when it comes down to
like attraction or or wherever right or
wrong simply is erroneous yeah like
right or wrong it doesn't morality why
it doesn't my dick is hard or not my
dick doesn't know what's right or wrong
it just knows hard and soft I like what
I see I'm getting hard yeah brother yeah
right or wrong doesn't come into it yeah
but yeah I just thought that was an
interesting thing to think about back
you know and as always man let's wrap it
up